you mentioned that
uh a theory of everything may be quite
difficult to come by
a theory of everything broadly defined
meaning like truly a theory of
everything
but let's look at a more narrow theory
of everything which is that
what the way it's used in often in
physics
is uh a theory that unifies
our current uh
laws of physics uh general relativity
uh quantum field theory do you have uh
thoughts on this dream of a of a theory
of everything in physics
how close are we is there any promising
ideas out there in your view
well it would be nice to have it would
be aesthetically pleasing
uh will be useful no probably not
well i shouldn't no it's dangerous to
say
that but probably not i think we not
not in certainly not in the uh
foreseeable future uh maybe to
understand black holes
yeah but that's that's yes maybe to
understand black holes
but that's not useful
[Laughter]
and and well not only i mean only to
understand
it's it's it's worse of course you know
it's not useful in the sense that we're
not going to be
basing any technology anytime soon on
black holes but it's it's
more severe than that i would say it's
that the kinds
of questions about black holes
that we can't answer within the
framework of existing theory
are ones that are not
going to be susceptible to astronomical
observation
in the foreseeable future they're
questions about
very very small black holes when uh
when quantum effects come into play or
uh so that black holes are
you know not not black holes they're
they're they're they're emitting
this discovery of hawking called hawking
radiation
which for astronomical black holes is a
tiny tiny effect that's no one have no
one has ever observed it's a prediction
that's never
been changed like supermassive black
holes that doesn't apply no
no the the predicted rate of radiation
from those black holes is so tiny that
it's absolutely unobservable and is
overwhelmed by all kinds of other
effects
uh so uh
so it's not practical in the sense of
technology it's not even practical
in the sense of application to astronomy
we our existing theory of
general relativity and quantum theory
and our theory of the the different
fundamental forces
is perfectly adequate to all prop
all problems of uh
technology for sure uh
and almost all
problems of astrophysics and cosmology
that appear except with the with the
notable exception
of the extremely early universe if you
want to ask what happened before the big
bang or what happened right at the big
bang
uh which would be a great thing to
understand of course
uh yes we don't but but what about the
engineering question
so if we look at uh space travel so
uh i think you've spoken with him uh
eric weinstein
really um uh you know he says
things like we want to get off this
planet his intuition is
almost a motivator for the engineering
project
of space exploration in order for us to
crack this problem of becoming a
multi-planetary species
we have to solve the physics problem his
intuition is like if we figure out this
what he calls the source code which is
like
like like like a theory of everything
might give us clues
on how to start hacking the fabric of
reality
like getting shortcuts right it might i
can't say that you know
i can't say that it won't but i can say
that
in the 1970s and early 1980s
we achieved
huge steps in understanding matter
qcd much better understanding of the
weak interaction
much under better understanding of
quantum mechanics in general
and it's had minimal uh uh minimal
impact on time on rocket design
unprecedented on rocket design on
anything any technology
whatsoever and now we're talking about
much more esoteric things
and since i don't know what they are i
can't say for sure that they won't
affect technology but i'm very very
skeptical that
they would affect technology the uh
uh the because you know to access them
you need to
very exotic circumstances to make new
kinds of particles with high energy you
need accelerators that
you know it's very expensive and you
don't produce many many of them and so
forth you know
it's just uh it's a pipe dream i think
yeah about space exploration
yes i'm not sure exactly what he has in
mind and
uh but uh to me
uh it's more a problem of
of i don't know something between
biology
and and uh and uh maybe a little ai
and information processing what you mean
how should i
i think human bodies are not well
adapted
to space even mars or even you know
which is the closest thing to a kind of
human environment that we're going to
find anywhere close by
uh very very difficult to maintain
humans on mars
uh and gonna be you know very expensive
and very you know
very unstable and but i think the pros
however uh if we
take a broader view of what it means
to bring human civilization
outside of the earth if we're satisfied
with
you know sending minds out there that we
can
converse with and actuators and that
that we can manipulate and
sensors that we can get feedback from i
think that's
where it's at i'm sure i think that's so
much
so much more realistic and uh
and i think that that's the long-term
future of uh
space exploration it's not hauling human
bodies all over the place
and that's that's that's just silly
but it's it's possible that it's human
bodies
so like you said it's a biology problem
what's possible
is that we extend human lifespan
in some way just we have to look at a
bigger picture it could be just like
you're saying
by sending robots with actuators and
kind of extending the the our limbs
but it could also be extending some
aspect of our minds of information it
could be
and it could be cyborgs it could be uh
it could be
now we're talking about it it could be
you know it could
it could be uh human brains or
cells that realize something like human
brain architecture
uh within uh
within artificial environments you know
shells if you like
that that are more adapted to the
conditions of space
and uh that yeah so that that's entirely
man machine hybrids
as well as sort of remote uh
outposts that we can communicate with i
think i think those those will happen
and uh yeah to me there's some sense in
which
as opposed to understanding the physics
of
the the the fundamental fabric of the
universe
i think getting to the physics of life
the physics of intelligence the physics
of consciousness
will the physics of information uh
that that that brings
from which life emerges that will allow
us to do space exploration
yeah well i think physics in the larger
sense has a lot to contribute here
not the physics of finding fundamental
new laws in the sense of uh
you know another quark or axions even
the uh but
physics in the sense of you know physics
has a lot of experience
in analyzing complex situations
and analyzing new states of matter and
devising new kinds of instruments that
do clever things we
you know the the physics in that sense
has enormous amounts to contribute
to uh this kind of endeavor but
i don't think that looking for
a so-called theory of any everything has
much
to do with it at all
you